une douche froide mes premiers pas dans
le monde de l'entreprise on était comme
une douche froide
mais pourquoi une douche froide la rive
à lundi matin de bonne heure dans un
grand cabinet anglo-saxon le conseil
avec 6 autres jeunes embauchés
un manager nous accueille et nous
présente le cabinet ses activités ses
codes
ils nous demandent de plancher sur un
sujet incompréhensible dans un délai
irréaliste
trois de mes camarades ont démissionné
j'ai rendu mon rapport je vais plus
jamais travailler avec ce manager
cette douche froide a été très bénéfique
elle m'a ouvert les yeux sur deux
constats premier constat bien de ce que
j'avais appris pendant mes études ne
l'avait servi si lire écrire et compter
et pourtant c'est sur mon diplôme comme
avait recruté ce qui m'a servi
c'est ce que m'a appris la natation
gérer son stress être précis bosser sans
eau cramé et c'est là la tête sous l'eau
que j'ai compris que la natation était
bien plus qu'un sport
second constat on m'avez toujours menti
on avait répété maintes et maintes fois
qu'il y avait d'un côté les études et de
l'autre les loisirs et le sport d'un
côté de travail de sérieux et de l'autre
la détente et l'amusement
comme si se demande était séparé par une
muraille de chine
mais non c'est faux là je suis devant
vous et en début de semaine j'étais en
costume cravate et j'enchaînais les
réunions c'est la même personne qui avec
ses qualités et ses défauts étaient en
début de semaine dans des salles de
réunion mes traits de caractère sont les
mêmes dans ma vie privée et dans ma vie
professionnelle que je sois en costume
cravate que je sois en jean baskets
ou en maillot vous le savez les
optimistes 13 des optimistes les anxieux
des anxieux les râleurs des râleurs en
toutes circonstances et c'est là la tête
sous l'eau que des passerelles entre la
natation et ma vie sont devenus évidence
savez-vous quel pourcentage d'eau que
nous avons dans le corps entre 60 et 70%
savez vous que les personnes qui sont à
côté de vous là ce soir ne rien dans la
tête vous non plus d'ailleurs
70 % de votre cerveau est remplie d'eau
j'ose pas vous donniez de pourcentage
pour mon cerveau après quarante cinq 45
ans de natation et pourtant on
entretient une relation ambivalente avec
l'eau nous sommes des êtres à que
remplit tous et nous entretenons une
relation ambivalente avec l'eau elle
oscille entre le plaisir l'appréhension
et la peur vous souvenez tous de vos
premières brasses les miennes ont eu
lieu en méditerranée
je m'en souviens comme si c'était hier
j'ai appris à nager parce que mes
parents en avaient assez de me courir
après sur la plage oui j'étais un enfant
un peu turbulents ils ont vite vu que
nager me calmer aussi ils m'ont inscrit
dans un club de natation
c'était il ya 45 ans environ
depuis
l'eau et la natation sont devenus de
bons conseilleurs ce que j'ai appris sur
moi sur les autres sur la vie en société
je lui ai appris grâce à la natation
pourquoi la natation est une école de la
vie il ya une quinzaine de minutes
j'étais derrière
j'attendais de passer sur scène j'avais
une boule au ventre
voyez ce que je veux dire hélas cette
boule au ventre
c'est le pouls qui accélère c'est la
gorge qui se serrent c'est la bouche qui
est sèche
tout le monde connaît ce phénomène avant
un moment important un examen un
entretien une audition un rendez vous
galant un talk personne ne m'a expliqué
comment gérer ces quinze minutes c'est
la natation qui m'a appris
pourquoi la natation m'a appris à gérer
ces 15 minutes
est ce que vous connaissez l'endroit le
plus redouté par les nageurs cet endroit
c'est la chambre d'appel vous êtes
réunit quinze minutes avant votre
épreuve avec tous vos adversaires
tous ont le trouillomètre à zéro
qu'ils soient champions olympiques
champions de france nageurs de niveau
départemental
tous après en nation de l'appel dans la
chambre d'appel
vous pouvez perdre une course nous dit
camille lacourt notre champion français
et du dos crawlé dans la chambre d'appel
c'est le royaume des petites phrases de
l'intox
et c'est dans la chambre d'appel que
vous sortez de votre zone de confort
c'est la chambre d'appel qui m'a obligé
à trouver des réponses pour gérer ces 15
minutes mais réponse une année mes deux
fils se sont retrouvés ensemble en
chambre d'appel aux championnats de
france de natation
l'une avait le regard noir elle ne
parlait pas l'autre pyatt et laquelle à
la bonne solution n'en sais rien elles
sont tellement différentes
ce qui marche pour l'une ne marchera pas
automatiquement pour l'autre regardez
michael phelps dans le chambre d'appel
michael phelps et 28 médailles
olympiques 23 titres olympiques
moi personnellement j'ai pas envie
d'aller lui demander à cette fille la
chambre d'appel
tenez je vous présente césar cielo cesar
cielo et double recordman du monde du 50
m et du 100 m nage libre
ses pectoraux sondes seront bientôt
aussi célèbre que ses performances
alors non madame je parle pas de leur
forme
je parle de leurs couleurs cesar cielo
l'état bruyamment dans la chambre
d'appel
c'est sa méthode pour gérer ce moment
alors messieurs lundi matin n'avaient
pas tambouriner sur vos pectoraux et
dire ensuite ici je vous l'assuré il
faut faire comme césar cielo pour se
concentrer maintenant
choisissez une main tous repayer vaudois
mettez le pousse à l'intérieur voyez
cette phalange elle fait 2 à 3 cm 2 cm
c'est ce qu'il a manqué à florent
malades ou cet été à rio pour être
champion olympique
2 cm
c'est un centième de seconde laurent
wolf and manaudou fait 34 mouvements de
bras sur un 50 m nage libre
un centième c'est une main qui rentre
mal sanaa puits qui fuit sept bassins
qui tourne nager m'a appris à être
précis avant de viser la perfection et
avec l'âge je me suis rendu compte que
visait la perfection était épuisant
viser la précision et ludique et c'est
stimulant
lequel des deux nageurs selon vous gagne
c'est celui de gauche c'est michael
phelps celui de droite
le serbe milorad cavic fait une course
parfaite il fait 100 m peel
sauf que pour arrêter le chronomètre
électronique
il faut appliquer une pression de 15 kg
sur la plaque qui est fixé sur le mur
d'arrivée
michael phelps nages 100 m et 2 cm il
arrive lancé il touche plus fort ils
arrêtent de chronomètre un centième
avant qu à vis de certains vous disent
que la victoire se joue à des détails ou
à un détail mais si la victoire se joue
à un détail c'est que c'est le plus
important
en natation tout compte
même la touche à l'arrivée d'une course
aux jeux olympiques de 2008 à pékin
michael phelps réalise un exploit
incroyable
il gagne huit titres olympiques donc 5
dans une épreuve individuelle
il a nagé en fait quatorze épreuves
individuelles dont 1 400 4 nages dont 1
200 m papillon
ce sont des apports des épreuves qui
sont éprouvante sur le plan physique
qu'est ce qui a été déterminant pour
qu'il puisse réussir ce programme
titanesque
ce qui avait été déterminant c'est la
récupération
quel est l'endroit le plus important
pour un nageur dans une compétition
c'est le bassin de récupération
la seule chose qui compte
quand vous avez terminé votre épreuve
c'est d'aller récupérer faire baisser la
tension vous ressourcez vous assure
c'est un pur plaisir
et combien de fois j'ai vu dans les
entreprises des collaborateurs qui a
enchaîné les projets qui a enchaîné les
réunions qui enchaîné les rendez vous
personne ne m'a dit que la récupération
était aussi importante et qui m'a dit
qu'il valait mieux être précis que
parfait qui m'a dit comment gérer ces
quinze minutes avant un moment important
vous l'aurez compris ma source
d'inspiration c'est la natation nage et
me donne du souffle au sens propre comme
au sens figuré
nager et vous vous découvrirez et vous
découvrirez les autres la natation m'a
donné des clés à tel point que j'ai pris
l'habitude de dire on manage comme mon
âge et réciproquement
alors je vous dis à très bientôt sur les
bords du bassin mais mais au fait quel
est votre source d'inspiration merci
[Applaudissements]